Quinceanera is a coming-of-age.
It's basically a girl turning into a young woman...
...and her parents are showing society that she is all grown-up.
Most little girls dream about their wedding.
Hispanics, most little girls dream about the day that they're gonna turn 15...
...and become a quinceanera...
...and their mom is dreaming about the day...
...that their daughter turns 15.
All the family comes.
It's a very important way to bring people together.
You look very good at it.
It doesn't matter where you come from in the part of the world.
We're all coming together to celebrate a quinceanera.
So it doesn't matter where you come from...
...because everybody loves a good party.
People from other cultures, they're intrigued by it.
It's something that maybe they kind of heard about it a little bit.
They see that it's a party, it's a celebration.
So I think it's something that they will embrace and love...
...and maybe even want to do it for their daughters.